oh yeah yeah this one he looks uh I
don't know man he might be like the new
gay woke version you know I'm down I'll
roll with that
[Music]
this one is just something that's
currently going on right now they're
still trying to find who's gonna play
the next 007. oh yeah because it's not
Idris Alba no more no and uh or Henry
Cavill they don't know who it's gonna be
they should have seal
seal because he has a British accent if
they're looking for a black guy or a
British accent you're right you want to
know what what's keeping people like
that from for keeping it from being an
Easy Choice his age yeah it is because
the seal is old now well it's not that
they're that so much that they're old
because Daniel Craig when he got the
role was already Daniel Craig was like
yeah he's old but the thing is the
contract is a 12-year commitment because
it's always like it's gonna be like five
movies still right exactly there's no
telling how fast they can get them done
so they need you to be committed to
being bond for 12 years and then they're
like I don't want to do just that I want
to do other movies too well you also
don't want to be 50 something and having
to still be Bond you know well Tom
Cruise could do it
but then like I mean Sean Connery was I
mean he was a little older too but then
the way that the Bond movies are now
it's much more action based yeah more
physically demanding yeah also did
anybody see that uh like uh no time to
die slash Bond documentary that uh
Daniel Craig did no about his journey
becoming Bond and stuff like that
it was really crazy it's not super long
I don't remember what [ __ ] streaming
platforming on maybe Apple TV I think at
the time this one no time to die was
coming out but it was really really good
watch I had coveted that's why I watched
it
um he was talking about how uh uh when
he became Bond bond has such a huge like
brand identity you know like history
that's like so many epic movies in the
story and stuff like that that when he
became Bond everybody hated on him super
hard the first one yeah his very first
one before Casino Royale right because
it was a different style he has a
different style upon yeah so uh he got
he wasn't ready for that press
everybody's just talking [ __ ] on him
there was like
um a bond not blonde.com is the website
started going up as well petitions were
assigned in like the tens of thousands
to like have it recasted like so he you
know there's a lot of social anxiety and
pressure that like who was the original
one Sean Connery original original I
think was Sean Connery yeah oh he was
the first there had to be people before
him no wait wasn't he um brunette the
first one no wasn't it literally there's
that I think it was Sean Connery there's
one other dude there was uh something
more
Richard Moore no was it rich Moore I
thought it was Richard Moore maybe not
which one's the brunette one the 90s one
cheers oh it really was Sean Connery
right wow 1962. you know why because
there's that Thai one with the little
dude yeah there's a little dude yeah the
little henchman who's always like uh
[ __ ] what does he say what the Filipino
it's like hasbula's like a rival Abdul
he looks like him which one is that but
yeah anyways uh they they talked
what are you talking about you know and
then they talk about the [ __ ] uh how
it like everybody expects so much from
Bond but then he ends up the fun the
funny thing is like Paparazzi like hide
in the sand for that very first scene or
one of those scenes in Casino real where
it comes out of the water yeah so
apparently Paparazzi like dug themselves
into that beach that morning holy [ __ ]
and then they do that scene where he
comes out the water all [ __ ] like
Nearly Naked and just buff as [ __ ]
jacked yeah they Paparazzi that moment
they they throw it on tabloids and then
suddenly everybody's like okay never
mind this bond is hella hard and sexy
yeah and then everybody he was down for
it after that I remember seeing it it's
my favorite Bond because he's the most
realistic one
also Casino Royale is like a sick ass
movie
he took those nut checks
he just kept going
I'm like he's like you barely even
grazed it I was like wow that scratched
the left one yeah yeah do the left to
the left everybody will know that you
died scratching my balls like that's
just hardcore I love the uh narrative
with those those uh movies because
that's when he like fell in love and
then never again remember that yeah yeah
yeah trade so it really shows with
Vesper why he's acting like that in the
future if this was looked at he misses
her and then he talks about in that in
that documentary too though like after a
couple uh of the movies it's so tall
like such a taxing uh experience both
like mentally like everything around
like the world is like you are now Bond
you are no longer like Daniel Craig yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's like it's
like Carlton him and Carlton Banks yeah
or Steve Urkel Jaleel White yeah you
become something that's so iconic that
it's bigger than who you are like you
can't walk out on the street without
like being that person as well and it
changed everything he didn't want to do
like the last movie or some [ __ ] that's
why it's true like not everyone even
wants that role I actually didn't like
Daniel Craig as Bond no he didn't when
you watched the movie or like well the
movie's great but in my image bond is
supposed to be like a no he's like a
gentleman Warrior right so like
Daniel pretty gentlemen I think it's
like an action movie to me like the
style and everything it became more of
an action movie than more of like a like
a Playboy players yeah yeah yeah like a
Kingsman with gadgets yes yes because
he's more like a Navy SEAL Now versus a
clever like a spy like cunning well he
he is he has those elements but then
like he does muscle his way out of
certain things it's too like realistic
in a sense but that was kind of like
half of the point right like trying to
take it back to a more raw actually
physical capable like person versus like
these spy situations where you get to
like click a button on something and
that like turns into a Megazord and you
get the blast your way you know what I
mean watch becomes a blue yeah which
which is why I feel like they had to
tone it down in the Artistry like Q
ended up being like this young scientist
who only gives him a gun that's like
registered you know what I mean like
they tried to simplify it so then um
that's what I said Joe just Joe let me
get your impression without knowing
anything about these people these are
all the people that could possibly
become Bond let me know your first
impression yes or no each of them
is that bond to you [ __ ] no sorry that's
Joe's answer I say [ __ ] notice it
depends on his he's his Mouse too big
but it depends it depends on his vibes
this guy to me looks like a [ __ ] frat
boy I can't go he's not he's not he's
not he's not he doesn't look smart
Justin Timberlake oh my God he's too
pretty yeah no he's a little too young
pretty remember he's got 12 years to do
this though even worse he had some
Squidward who's that
Squidward is that Harry Styles scare
nobody dude all right how about that
maybe maybe yeah yeah yeah yeah I could
see him he's probably the most British
looking one to me
Slumdog Millionaire it looks like he is
yeah he could pull it off for sure yeah
definitely
you know what because there's been a
[ __ ] ton of the Beast he's all right
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah this one he looks
uh I don't know man he might be like the
new gay woke version you know I'm down
I'll roll with that okay yeah I'm down
with that oh my God shaken mastered yeah
who's that oh Aaron what's his face
that's a quicksilver yeah yeah yeah yeah
no I'm not going
to watch him I'm gonna kick outside
appeal and Gadget appeal how about this
oh hell yeah Marty yeah Tom Hardy he's
he's an interesting candidate because
he's just too Jack to be 007 he's one of
the only people that uh won't discuss it
yeah they asked him like oh do you want
to be Bond and all he said was I can't
say anything because the moment you
speak on it you don't get it oh
just like taking so he does want to be
Bond but he understands that when you
talk about a role too much about wanting
it they don't give it to you maybe it's
the beard but to me he feels like a
retired special like Ops guy like taken
four back and then he's all like I'm
retired and they're like come on we need
you I [ __ ] with Tom Hardy's World
though most of those dudes are former
Navy SEALS or uh Special Forces like the
the CIA field agents are former seals
and former like Delta guys
[Music]
man like
no hate to the Asians but
he's too pretty bro like I need him to
look a little more like he doesn't look
military to me okay that's fair that's
fair all right sorry next shark it looks
like I'm gonna wear a model you know
yeah he's good for a romance position
who the [ __ ] is this Tom Brady who's
that name is
[Laughter]
maybe maybe I think I'm a Tom Hardy guy
so far yeah I'm Tom Hardy and the guy
before Tom Hardy maybe maybe whatever
he's got nice eyes though huh all the
white guys are babies babies Tom
Hiddleston Loki definitely not no
definitely not if you want to do James
Bond the comedy
bro that definitely got a weak jaw dude
[ __ ] that weak jaw maybe maybe maybe oh
yeah yeah yeah I think oh it's from Star
Wars
yeah like they have to I have to believe
that they could kick some ass okay or I
have to believe that they were in the
military oh
now his jaw's weak I have to be British
because you know those [ __ ]
come over here steal our rolls they like
kind of have to be can we go there steal
their rules
I do think double got [ __ ] he needs
shoulder sleeves because he's got weak
shoes how about that Jake Gyllenhall
oh
Oliver Jackson Cohen shoulder
dude like
do you believe a six foot 135 pound guy
to be a [ __ ] special ops guy yeah
that's true
no dude I think that's oh it's not the
last one how about this maybe maybe yeah
yeah
I don't know it says maybe they're all
British guys what does it say
I can't even read The Gangs of London
gangs of London yeah they get the UK
like all right how about that yeah Lance
Armstrong yeah yeah look at his jaw
he looked too Square to me all of his
roles all of his roles are like way too
Square geez yeah that is a chick he was
the assistant in uh [ __ ] The Bourne
Identity or whatever right let's see Tom
Hopper dude okay that's it I'm a Tom
Hardy vote yeah Tom Hardy for me Tom
Hardy has an unfair Advantage because
we've seen the dopes and we like him we
like him yeah he does some weird stuff
we gotta give a new person a chance I
like the Kick-Ass guy as my second vote
who's the Kick-Ass guy oh interesting
because the Kick-Ass guy has also done a
lot of other military like spots and
he's just been like a captain in like a
lot of like other SEAL movies and [ __ ]
like that he knows how to play that role
he's been trained in all that military
stuff he's got that hard ass look but he
also has that kid ass look so I think
he's got a lot of range it was good in
tenant and bullet train
yeah he was good intended I haven't seen
bullet chain so just as a closing thing
uh you guys know that there's currently
uh open betting on who's gonna be really
and here's the spread for the odds so
all right I bet on a hospital dude
so um yeah Henry cavill's still the
number one spot that they think is going
to become bond is that listed in order
because look at the the spread on oh
yeah it is yeah yeah yeah yeah because
then these are least likely so the the
reward wait who's Henry Superman yeah
you can't have Superman playing him
that's not fair I think he would do a a
pretty cool job though but I don't know
if he's like the 12-year Bond I think
he's like a fantasy because Bond got
some internal demons too you know what I
mean it's like a oh it's true yeah also
they did say that the new Bond is gonna
have more sensitivity towards like
misogynistic uh situation oh because
bond is so toxic masculinity oh so they
are gonna try to fix that a little it's
gonna be a tough error you know how
we're gonna completely fix this Brett
man rock as
yeah yeah
I rock as Bond Hawaii secret agent
it could be James or Jenna Bond we don't
know yeah he just does everything nice
they break it down I don't really know
these people